what is happening there citizens the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
to talk something very specifically post
secret Invasion finale John how are you
I'm good I haven't been the real me in
years how are you oh my god oh that
undercuts so much of your journey here
on the real region personal
breakthroughs together as friends or
moot now so ladies and gentlemen uh
leave a like that would be very much
appreciated also wanted to give a
mention to our exclusive Ahsoka Tano a
soda shirt uh it is only available until
July 31st after that no longer available
it's one of the great ways to support
the channels by picking yourself up one
plus it's just a really cool shirt and
I'm I'm sad it can only be available for
a limited time it's just the way it is
so ladies and gentlemen there has been a
lot of talk about the real Roadie being
revealed for how long skrody has
essentially been around in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and there's a very
common belief that he has been around
pretty much since the events of Captain
America Civil War due to the fact that
he was in a hospital gown when he was
revealed in secret Invasion that just
led to a trickle of thoughts it's
something that John and I did not quite
touch on because we didn't take it
immediately as that's confirmation it's
been since Civil War because at the very
end of Captain America Civil War is not
in a hospital gown uh he is you know
bonding with Tony that's this is from
the Stan Lee Cameo happens when he's
working on getting his feet back on the
ground and metaphorically and physically
speaking but yeah the last time we did
see Rody in a hospital gown and the only
time we did was in the events of Captain
America Civil War so maybe he got
scrotied during uh his time while he was
in the MRI machine the vision just let
it happen but yeah it's my thoughts uh
on this and as we were talking it sort
of let down a trickle of a lot of things
of what made what makes this if this is
indeed the time frame for how long
Roadie has been scrotie in my opinion
and I'm imagining you probably feel the
same way it makes a lot of it a little
dumb in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and it actually has me a bit concerned
for what's going to be happening with
armor Wars moving forward uh and
honestly like if you guys in the
comments have a completely different
take or if there's something that we say
where you're like well you know what
Greg and John actually maybe you you
will be able to change your minds we are
open-minded individuals so please leave
your thoughts down below after hearing
what we gotta say of course but let's
dive into it all right first and
foremost the thing that immediately
bothered me because I got three things
that I want to talk about one it
pertains to Nick Fury specifically
another pertaining to scrotie
specifically how I think that actually
makes his character a little dumber and
three how it mainly undercuts the
Journey of what Roadie has been on from
Infinity War to even in his little
appearance in Falcon in the Winter
Soldier and I want to start off with
that one because that's the biggest one
for me that I think is really undermined
if this is indeed the time frame that he
has been Roadie because Roadie was there
for the Battle of wakanda in Infinity
War which is a very big battle and you
know full battle it was it was a
meaningful battle and he was around for
when everyone got blipped he was part of
that main Avengers lineup for what would
become the cast for Avengers end game
which of course explores The Five-Year
blip and if Roadie wasn't present for
that I mean what are the convenient odds
would Roadie have had to have been
blipped in order could Roadie have been
real Roadie have been sorority can still
Stick Around by maintaining all the
things and of but the memories would
have to go away from the like the mind
melder machine yeah so that's what we
have to remember you're really lucked
out yeah what happens if that zaps away
do you remember just what you can recall
or is it just like the whole Bank of
data is just gone now yeah I don't
really know how it works do we need some
clarity on the rules regardless that
doesn't even really matter at this point
it's the fact that scrotie was the one
experiencing The Five-Year blip scrotie
was the one who did the time traveling
and hung out with nebula scrotie was the
one who owned the line about time
traveling back and murdering baby Thanos
scrotie how could they scrotie was the
one who was there for Tony Stark's death
yeah these are things that Roadie did
not get to experience then if he was
indeed you know not real Roadie for it
you know what I mean and to me I'm like
that should factor in so much to
rhodey's character development and now
you are stripping him away from that
yeah well and two that makes me think
too that that's just such a thematically
full circle idea image that he should be
there for Tony upon his death as Tony
was there for him upon this catastrophic
moment that changes the course of his
life forever in Civil War yeah and so
like if it's not actually him yeah the
Beats of the character the juice of the
character are given to this other
character but now who's a different guy
who we haven't really had any time to
latch on to and the problem is that in
secret Invasion he's like so kind of
transparent in his approach to things
that you then have to wonder well if
he's been a you know scroll this whole
time where did all his subtlety go and
his like Nuance of knowing the character
he's supposed to portray yeah yeah and I
do want to dive a little bit more into
that in a second because the thing to
keep in mind is this is going off of the
fact that you know the the belief is
this has been around Civil War it might
not be you know at the end of the day
it's a hospital gown and maybe they
didn't have time to strip everybody but
they did have time to put him in they
could have just captured him when he was
at a hospital you know doing another
follow-up on his physical therapy or
something like that it's as many many
times it could have been after end game
for all we know this just seems to be
the popular belief right now and I'm
just saying I don't subscribe to this as
the thing that would be effective for
for it because then when we're going
into armor Wars that would mean then
that Roadie is going to have to learn
all of this information that has
happened over the last few years and
while one part of my brain goes actually
that could be compelling that could be
very interesting Roadie is someone who's
like uh I got this responsibility now
I'm leading my own movie you know yeah
and now I'm also just learning that I've
been potty swapped and my friends were
through these horrible catastrophic
events without me and my best friend
died you know Tony Stark's dead now and
and I'm the one who looks the most like
Iron Man so I got it like so I gotta
fill the shoes man yeah so I think there
is something really compelling they
could do the problem is trust in the
writing Disney Plus shows are six
episodes long on average and there's
been a very common complaint about how
you have the most potential to do the
best writing out of the MCU you have the
most potential to do the best character
Explorer operation out of the MCU and
I'm like what a weight this guy has to
take on now and what a traumatic
experience he has to now adopt into the
portrayal of being Roadie and armor Wars
the thing is armor is not going to be a
show anymore it's going to be a movie
now so a movie allows you even less time
to deal with it it has even less time to
make a compelling piece for your
character and they're like yeah we want
it to be a something where it could be a
multiple movie Arc for him I'm like how
many freaking multiple movie arcs or
multiple movies are they saying they're
gonna do and then a sequel comes out
like freaking forever from now whenever
it's released this whole idea of oh we
can make something kind of interesting
for Roadie I just don't have the faith
that they're going to be able to pull it
off on us like yeah it's a matter of
will you actually commit to that because
step by step and especially I think
through phase four they have like
promised a lot of things and then sort
of like half committed to maybe sort of
delivering on them and the thing about
transmuting a show version of armor Wars
into a movie version is that you'll also
lose a portion of the audience who isn't
checking in with the Disney Plus shows
for a pretty big Revelation about this
character who then might be the people
who are like lost when Gamora was a
whole different person in Guardians 3 if
they didn't see all the intervening
chapters and stuff like that so I feel
like it it murkies the water that much
more moving forward and forward again
like you said the trust of are they
really gonna you know commit to putting
this thread in a prominent way
throughout multiple movies even if
they're not Roadie movies because you
know they're not going to release like
five Roadie movies in the next several
years you know so how and and that could
hail an interesting change to their
storytelling approach because hey I mean
comic books especially as these
universes grow in the pages certainly
characters are traversing and kind of
crossing over all the time and being
significant supporting characters in
other Heroes main stories or whatever
but again thus far it doesn't seem like
that's exactly what they're doing with
all these medias so yeah it's like a
cool thought but nothing suggests that
that's what they're actually going to do
I agree I mean we'll probably get less
Roadie I mean Papa agar you know the
people champ as the world likes to call
him chips yeah he's the man for the for
the average individual The Working Man
yeah yeah he wants he's like less less
Marvel yeah you guys are diluting
yourself which I mean you know to some
extent there is a kernel of Truth to
that because hey people get spread thin
in terms of the richness of the ideas
spread them out a little bit and like
really put some impact on it now we got
the idea too that Nick Fury apparently
could never pick up on this fact who's
like the greatest Mastermind and
discerner of people and character and
Espionage and all that yeah yeah yeah
there's like an actual Nick Fury was
around for a while with scrotie on this
time frame then after the events of end
game it was Talos Fury you know scrotie
Roadie yeah did they know about each
other
no I obviously did yeah
Taylor's Fury couldn't pick up on it
either so no one could pick up on this
and to me I go well I feel like one of
them should have been able to pick up on
this for how you know great their Acumen
is presented they should have one of
them should have been and that's one of
the things I'll let's out of all all the
complaints I have I'm like that's one of
the ones I'll let slide because the idea
is they're supposed to be so good at
being undercover that you can't even
detect right even amongst other Scrolls
so sure let's let that slide to me
though I think it makes actual scrotie
that we got with a confirmed one that we
have in secret Invasion and even dumber
portrayal mainly because hey it does the
performance just doesn't line up with a
supposed scroties we now had it it does
not properly line up for the long game
go where'd the long game go
um it it does bother me that the show
itself lost so much of its gray
conversation the things that made it
compelling that not one part of scrotie
in this thing about F humans never
factored in the The Avengers experience
this scrotie hat yeah everything that
the this scrotie did to restore 50 of
that you know this is gonna cause an
opportunity how many Scrolls got snapped
yeah and okay fine well that they got to
get back to the main objective why would
this scrotie after everything be like no
I gotta follow graphic you know like
that's just whatever fine it made it
feel like this was scrotie number two or
three it made it feel like this is yeah
this is scrotie who's been around maybe
since post-end game that's what that's
what it feels like so that's why I'm
saying this whole idea that it's Civil
War if that's the case I think it's dumb
and here's here's the thing that really
and we kept pointing it out scrotie
being around in Infinity war and an end
game how come he never freaking used his
suit
he clearly has his War Machine suit then
that he can access and the entire time
to defend himself or fight against stuff
he never once involved himself as well
like I could I could use my suit so that
whole Hospital scene in the animal
where's your suit it'd be too greedy
I've already got my shape-shifting
scroll Powers it's too much of an
advantage I don't want to use the actual
Weaponry no he's protecting the
president after a terror a terrorist
attack of sorts like the what better a
time and it's something you have to know
especially for what they're planning
it's like an asset to your false flag to
your genuine cause like why wouldn't you
if you had a scrotie roadie you put him
in the suit as much as possible yeah I I
think that this whole concept of him
being a civil since the ransom Civil War
I personally don't really like I think
there's room for potential but I'm
getting a little worn out on feeling
like
the common consensus keeps being it was
fun but I'm kind of finding it
forgettable and there's a lot of flaws
because everything keeps going back to
the potential it had yeah it never quite
matching the potential and secret
invasion is a is another Prime case of
what happened there so whatever
potential this has for Roadie I'm
currently not sold on it and nor will I
go in like ready to hate it or anything
of that fact I always go in with an open
mind I want them to nail these things I
always want them nailed it I mean even
for secret Invasion that came out that
debuted to not good reviews barely fresh
on Rotten Tomatoes we still walked away
though go like with the first couple
episodes
I love this this is a great and then the
show became what it became then that's
just where we stand but where do you
guys stand do you like this reveal do
you like this twist do you think they'll
handle it really well what do you really
disagree with us on what do you agree
with us on let us know in the comments
seriously like if you have a compelling
case in the comments except the word
compelling so many times if you haven't
did this blow
together or did you see this and go oh
cool wait a second yeah yeah hold on
what what do you find uh interesting
about all this leave them in the
comments thank you for being here and uh
we'll talk with you soon